carved into the foothills of some of the
world's highest peaks the Kathmandu
Valley has been a unique witness to the
development of Buddhism and Hinduism the
valley is dotted by more than a hundred
sacred spots temples stupas monasteries
many shared between the worshipers of
the two faiths stupas are Buddhist
shrines and boudhanath is one of the
largest in Nepal built in the 5th
century it is meant to be an expression
of the Buddhist faith to reach the main
stupa worshipers must climb thirteen
steps one for each of the thirteen
stages of wisdom needed to reach
enlightenment the stupa sits at the
center of a symbolic representation of
the universe and from the base of its
tower the Buddha's eyes gaze in each
direction
the stupids surrounded by a circuit of
prayer wheels inscribed with Buddhist
mantras pilgrims circle the complex
spinning the wheels so that the mantras
are released continuously into the world
in a sacred grove not far from the urban
heart of Katmandu since the 3rd century
pashupatinath temple complex the site is
crowded with Hindu shrines it's here on
the waters of the bug Madi River that
many Nepalese Hindus cremate their dead
the Swayambhunath stupa sits perched on
a hill overlooking the kathmandu valley
it is believed that the valley was once
a lake that was drained by the
embodiment of Buddhist wisdom known as
the Monkey Temple the complex draws more
than worshipers and tourists these
rhesus macaques are regarded as sacred
descendents of the lice that plagued the
god of wisdom the Buddhist shrines and
Hindu temples are situated around the
main stupa
[Music]
many worshipers believe the stupa sits
atop an entrance to the underworld the
worshipers been prayer wheels light
candles and pray for protection thanks
or enlightenment for centuries Buddhists
and Hindus have worshiped side-by-side
in the Kathmandu Valley for both
Kathmandu is not just holy ground its
common ground
you